Hi, everyone.
I hope you had a great lunch.
So, let's get started.
This talk is about augment ing empathy, and
what I mean by that is basically that you
already have empathy, but there can be some
things or tools that you use actually to augment
that a little bit more, to understand some
situation s and to make things clear, and
we will be using CSS, SVG, and WebRTC to do
this.
My name is she she.
Basically, I do a lot of R&D to try to look
at new technologies.
Previously, I used to work at Opera.
It's a company based in Mumbai, and it does
a lot of accessibility consulting, auditing,
and stuff like that.
It is also an enterprise with a social mission,
and part of that mission is providing opportunities
to people with disabilities, and so much so
that about 70 per cent of our staff are people
with disabilities.
One of the person in the staff is Ahmed who
was born with with low vision.
Back in 2005, he met with an accident, and
he lost sight in his right eye.
So, but that didn't stop him.
He still had an interest in tech, and he ended
up become a trainer and goes to a lot of different
conferences, trainings and workshops to teach
people how to make their site successful.
When I got to know him, and we got talking,
there were - I quickly realised there were
a lot of things which people who have low
vision were confused about, particularly with
his condition.
A lot of times, people couldn't understand
the way in which his vision worked or didn't
work.
We also had people who were low vision, and
I talked with them as well.
I talked to their colleagues, friends and
families, and caretakers as well.
One trend kept coming again and again which,
a lot of times, it was difficult for for people
with low vision really to articulate what
their condition was, how they basically saw
the work, and sometimes, people who didn't
have low vision couldn't understand what was
happening.
So I did a little bit more research.
I actually consulted an ophthalmologist as
well to get the medical perspective from someone
who has dealt with hundreds of thousands of
cases.
One thing was very, very clear: low vision
is a very generic term.
If you say, "Someone has low vision," with
a lot of times people assume it is a form
of myopia.
That can be the case.
That's not always the case.
Sometimes, you have glaucoma, macular degeneration
- all these things are there.
If you ask the random person on the street
what is macular degeneration, they might not
know.
One thing became clear, that one of the things
I could do is not help people with low vision
but actually help everyone else understand
what low vision is.
That's where the simulators come in.
I said, can we make something to simulate
what the vision is like?
And, if it is possible, can we use the web
to do this, and also gravy on top, if we can
use JavaScript less and SVG have CSS more,
that would be more awesome.
The first condition I chose was colour blindness,
and this is even more poignant here in Europe
because eight per cent of men and 0.5 of women
of northern European ancestry have some form
of red-green colour blindness, and the more
you talk to people who have red-green colour
blindness, the more you will see in the physical
world, not just in the online world but the
physical world, there's still a lot of stuff
in which you need to determine whether something
is red or green, right?
The most obvious example is traffic lights,
but that's not just the case.
If you have the MacBook charger, if you charge
it, and you want to look from afar whether
it is still charging, the only way to distinguish
it is whether it is red or green in colour.
That's it.
So I made a tool which you can actually simulate
the different conditions.
This is using WebRTC and applying SVG on top.
The reason why it is actually pretty useful
is because a lot of times, people get it wrong.
I asked a lot of people with normal 2020 vision,
what would it be like to live with colour
blindness and see something red in colour,
what would they see?
A lot of times, people become confused and
don't know and assume it will be a desaturated
version of that image.
That's not the case.
Over here, we can see that, in one condition,
you will have this bench as brown in colour.
On the other hand, you will have something
light greenish in colour.
The real colour is actually red.
How do we actually do this?
I use something called SVG colour matrix,
which is a set of matrix values that you provide.
It basically works like this.
You have an image.
Each and every image will have an RGBA value.
You have a matrix with a set of values over
here, and all you do is matrix-multiply the
values together to form a new colour for that
particular pixel.
You can define an SVG colour filter over here.
Then the colour matrix, and values, you can
write out all the values come are a-separated.
In the CSS, it is as simple as saying filter
URL, hashtag, whatever.
That's all very, very nice to know, right?
But it's one thing to have an academic or
mathematical perspective of how SVG colour
matrix works, and the other is to have an
intuitive understanding.
The only thing that I've seen which grants
you that is experimentation, unfortunately.
You can't get it how it works, just by learning
a few things.
You need to experiment.
Fortunately, if you Google, the SVG playground,
where you can mix and match different values
and see what the output would be, and that
gives a better perspective and a more intuitive
understanding.
I will be sharing the slides later on as well
with links to some really, really nice articles
opinion let's take this opportunity to know
about the matrix and put it in our pocket.
We will revisit this later on.
Now that we have a tool which can address
different colour blindness conditions, one
of the things that I also - when talking with
people with red-green colour blindness - I
say how do you distinguish between red and
green and nothing else?
It's a bit difficult to do so.
I made something which, for lack of a better
name, I called the red-green sheet.
On the left, you have one example of the test
which is generally a set of tests which is
used for people to diagnose colour blindness.
If you don't have colour blindness, you will
see 74.
If you do have it, you will see something
like 21.
Over here, let me just go back, you can see
I've made something where you're basically
isolating things into two categories.
If something is red, it goes into the left
category.
If something is green, it goes into the other
This is all done in real time, and it's done
using CSS and SVG.
The only JavaScript part is getting the camera
output.
So this is how we do it.
The first thing that we do is apply an SVG
filter, and the second thing we do is apply
a mixed blend mode of hue.
Simple, but it hides a lot of complexity behind
it.
Let's revisit this, see and go into a deeper
dive into what this means, and how this effect
is actually done.
To do that, let's go really, really back.
How many people watched Looney Toons when
they were a child?
Everyone.
All these cartoons use something called cell
animation - "cell" standing for celluloid
- and the reason why is these were transferring
sheets, and, generally speaking, in any kind
of animation, you had a bunch of characters
moving around, but you also had some background
which was static.
What you could do is basically have a sheet
where you just paint the background once and
be done with it, and all the other stuff you
can do with the character animations and put
one layer on top.
A lot of these animations were done like this
where the character animations were done by
one team, and the background animation or
painting was done by some other team in parallel,
and then the final result was putting those
layers on top of each other.
This was basically an early form of what we
call compositing.
Compositing and blending, the spec is based
off this, but come positing and blending has
been around for a long time, even as part
of SVG.
So what exactly is composting.
It is it's how to deal with - ...
what exactly is - it is named after Thomas
Duff who in 1984, they published a seminal
paper on how to deal with overlapping objects
- this exact thing called compositing.
At that time, they were in the early 1980s
working together on a small company called
Lucas Film which was doing a lot of pioneering
work when it came to digital graphics.
They basically said in that paper that, if
you have two layers, one on top of the other,
so the top layer is called a source layer,
the bottom layer is called a destination,
right?
So, in that overlapped portion, you can do
pretty much four things: first, none.
You don't show anything over there.
Second is the source in which you show the
top layer.
Third is the destination in which you show
the bottom layer, and the fourth, and more
interest interesting one, is show a combination
of both the top and bottom layer, right?
And this is where opacity and alpha channels
come in.
Coming back to our example, what we need to
do in the first half to recreate the effect
that we saw in the colour sheet is to somehow
make it black and white but own the red colour
showing.
So, in this case, what we do is, if you can
see the red-green and blue channels are all
zero, right?
In effect, what this matrix is doing is basically
taking this image and making everything transparent
except for the colours which have a little
bit of an R value.
Then we come posit it on the original image
to get some of the red stuff.
Value equals zero so it is totally desaturated.
Then we composite them on top to get the black
and white image with just the red showing.
All of this using SVG, nothing else.
Now, the first part is complete.
The second thing we want to do is to understand
blending and how that works.
So blending is basically how to deal with
the overlapped portion in terms of colours,
and the mixing of the colours.
So, for example, we have this particular layer.
And then you have a layer on top of it over
here.
So, there's a portion which is overlapping,
right?
How do we deal with the colours over here?
That is the essence of blending.
In a more practical example, let's see this
image.
We can have a few layers, we can mix and match
them through whatever we want to achieve this
particular final layer.
This is essentially what blending is, mixing
and matching different layers, to achieve
a final effect.
Let's come back to an example.
Over and over here, we have a container div
which is red in colour.
Inside this, we have the video, which is running.
Right now, we haven't applied any effects,
so it's just the normal colours.
The moment we apply the SVG filter we talked
about, everything is grey scale apart from
the red stuff.
Then we will apply a blank board.
We're applying a hue.
This works in the cell space.
It will take the hue from the top layer and
combine it with the saturation and luminosity
of the bottom layer, so, in this case, all
the black and white stuff will be basically
a grey area, whereas the rest will be bright
red, so ultimately you get this.
So it's just two lines, but it hides a lot
of complexity, and it's very, very important
to know the concept of layers and how it plays
into blending and compositing, and with JavaScript,
if you have a proper understanding of it.
One more thing that I worked on was macular
degeneration.
Sometimes, it's called age-related macular
If you have a visual, you can see what it
actually means.
It's sometimes also pretty tragic or heart-breaking,
because a lot of time, it affects people who
are older, and, by the time they have grandchildren,
and sometimes, they have a hard time seeing
the faces of their grandchildren, and that's
- and that's something which if someone else
comes in, that's something else which people
don't get, the human aspect of how it makes
people feel.
So anyways, like I was saying, if I have to
recreate this effect using SVG, or just CSS,
how do I do this?
Fortunately, in this case, I don't want to
use SVG.
I can use a radial gradient with a blend mode.
If you have a container detective which is
a radial gradient which is black to transparent,
and you combine it with the video output,
then you ply a mixed - apply a mixed blend
and multiply, and you get this kind of effect.
In most cases in web designs, you won't really
use this, but if you take the opposite of
it in which you have transparent to black
radial element and combine it with an image,
then apply the multiplier, then you can get
nice effects on images without using Photoshop,
which is really, really great.
One thing that I wanted is for you to put
it on top of your headsets.
Nowadays, our headsets are getting cheap,
and some of these allow these to use the background
to see on the other side.
Not all of them, but some allow you to do
that.
If you do, then you can actually do this.
You can have stereoscopic mode where you have
two video elements and you can go full screen
and use it as part of a VR to get a more immersive
experience.
If you want to do this, right, there are a
few things that you want to do.
First, you want to make sure that it displays
just one video on portrait mode and two videos
on landscape mode.
You have to detect whether something is in
portrait mode and hide the video.
So it - there is a lot of stuff going on over
here.
I also want to make sure that everything is
full screen so that you don't see the browser
and address bar, and once you're in that full-screen
mode, you don't want to switch between portrait
and landscape every time you're moving your
head, so you want to lock the orientation
as well.
This is how we do it.
You can have a full-screen API, the moment
something goes in full screen, we can use
the orientation lock API so that it doesn't
switch between portrait and landscape all
the time.
One more thing that I do is I use a CSS exclusively
for full screen as well, so, in this case,
I can use along with prefixes, the full screen
pseudo element.
This will just be applied on full screen.
One more thing that I do is of course have
custom CSS for the orientation.
If something is in portrait mode, it needs
a certain set of standards apply than in landscape
mode.
Here you have the media library for orientation
mode as well.
One thing people are not talking about but
shed is the fact that in PWAs, of you a lot
of display modes.
So you can load a PWA as a normal browser
tab, but once you install that PWA you can
open it up as a standalone app.
In that case, you don't have the browser address
bar which means you have increased screen
real estate that you need to account for and
do something with.
Hero, use the display mode standalone and
see what the display mode is, and, depending
upon that, you can have custom CSS.
One of the things that I've used, and one
last thing, that I leave you with is that
none of this actually matters.
It doesn't matter if you don't actually talk
with people and interact with people with
real disabilities.
That's really, really important.
I like this tweet, which was, retweet if you're
tabled and an inspiration.
If the person then stick around to get to
know you as a person.
It got 630 retweets by the time I screen shotted
this.
That's a big thing.
When you're talking about empathy, you really
need to kind of generate empathy somehow,
and the only way you can do it is actually
to be someone's friend, or be listening to
a person, not academically reading things
here and there, right?
That's one of the things about disability
simulators.
A lot of people think that, just because I
have interacted with a simulator, suddenly
I know everything about people with that particular
disability.
That's not true.
Human interaction is always always required.
A lot of times, people were able-bodied, they
put on a simulator, they struggle, and they
put it back down, and then they think everyone
with that disability is just struggling 24/7.
That's also wrong.
This is a tweet who says not every person
with a disability feels they are.
The insinuation that disability is equal to
suffering ... so, when it comes to empathy,
one layer is yes, you need to think about
what other people are finding challenging,
what problems people are facing, but the other
side is actually to get to know what they
want to do, what their potential is, what
they aim for, what are their goals in life,
and then what are you going to do about it,
right?
These tools that I try to make, I always forms
the idea that, okay, now, actually do a task
five times, because, by the fifth time, they're
not struggling so much.
Then they realise that, okay, people who have
these conditions have developed coping mechanisms,
and actually, kind of gotten used to it, and
now they're taking dysfunction just like everyone
else.
So, being empathic it's recognising a few
things.
It's multilayered.
You need to recognise the challenges that
people face, right?
And it could be something as simple as just
believing someone when they say they have
a problem, right?
It doesn't even apply to people with disabilities
but every kind of marginalised group.
Listen and believe them when they say they
have a problem.
The second thing is recognising the strength
and potential that people have, right?
So, if a person really wants to do something,
have faith in them.
I can give you a story of a person who went
- who was diagnosed with low vision.
A lot of well-meaning well-wishers said take
up pottery or handicrafts or something like
that.
It was coming from a good place but it wasn't
the right advice.
That person wanted to go in tech and do stuff
with computers.
Fortunately, she joined our company and is
now one of the top people over there.
The main thing to recognise is that what other
people are supposed to be doing, what people
are capable of doing under supporting that.
And ultimately, the way in which you display
your empathy has to be a combination of all
these things, just like blend modes, like
you have different layers, and you kind of
like mix and match between different colours,
the same thing has to be happening with your
approach to empathy as well.
So, recognise the challenges they face; recognise
they are capable, they have potential; and
then ultimately your action as well, because
empathy without action is useless.
That's the thought that I will leave you with.
Thank you so much!
[Applause]